today congress starts a week of debate
that could make or break president
biden's domestic agenda democrats plan
to have crucial votes on two bills that
demonstrate the party's priorities at
the cost of trillions of dollars in
spending nancy cordes is at the white
house nancy good morning
good morning nate well this is the
centerpiece of president biden's
platform and it is all coming to a head
this week house speaker nancy pelosi
says she is aiming to hold a vote on a
bipartisan infrastructure plan on
thursday but that all hinges on her
ability to round up the votes for a
second spending bill that is three times
as large
this is the vision of the president
democrats had a warning for potential
holdouts sunday the president's
priorities are on the line this week
this is the president's democratic
agenda the key part of the president's
agenda this is joe biden's bill
joe biden's bill is a huge 3.5 trillion
dollar package that includes new funding
for the child tax credit universal pre-k
home health care and much more
we'll keep government open house speaker
nancy pelosi says 95 percent of house
democrats are now on board but with such
a slim majority her party will need to
do even better than that if somebody
wants less than 3.5 trillion tell us
what you want to cut do you want to cut
the child care do you want to cut paid
leave what is it you want to cut the
margin for victory is narrow because
democrats cannot count on any republican
support they are in the midst of an
absolutely unprecedented very damaging
spending spree on a scale that we have
never seen a small breakthrough came
last night when two more centrist house
democrats announced they now support
passage of the package
i'm optimistic about this week it's
going to take the better part of the
week i think
without a deal on this bill progressives
are vowing to hold up another big biden
bill the bipartisan infrastructure
package worth another 1.2 trillion
dollars that would go towards rebuilding
roads and bridges this is washington i'm
sure there's going to be some kind of
compromise
democrats have imposed this deadline on
themselves to try to get this all done
this week because they know that the
longer this drags on the more likely it
is that problems start to pop up and it
only gets more difficult to pass major
legislation like this gail the closer we
get to next year's midterm elections
got it nancy thank you very much